ENTERTAINMENT LANDSCAPE.
>> Bret: ONE TO WATCH.
DEIDRE BOLTON, THANK YOU.
WE CONTINUE OUR REPORTING ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF THE FAMILY FARM.
THIS EVENING DOUG ON THE
STRUGGLE TO PRESERVE NOT JUST
THE LIVELIHOOD BUT A WAY OF
LIFE.
>> THIS WON'T BE TOO LONG BEFORE
WE HAVE TO CUT IT.
>> A SPRING TIME DELIVERY FOR
VIRGINIA'S FARMS.
THIS PLANTER PUTS 16 ROWS OF
SEED INTO THE GROUND.
EVERY LITTLE BIT HELPS TO
STRETCH RAZOR THIN PROFIT
MARGINS FOR THIS 100-YEAR-OLD
FAMILY BUSINESS.
>> I AM 4th IN LINE AND I HOPE
MY SON OR DAUGHTER WILL BE FIFTH
OR BOTH.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY WILL.
>> YOU THINK ABOUT THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE COMMITMENT
THAT COSTS MORE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE THE FARM OWN INCLUDING THE
LAND ITSELF.
THE UNPREDICTABLE OF THE SEED
STOCK AND THE WEATHER.
SO MANY THINGS CAN GO WRONG.
>> THE NUMBERS ARE STARTLING.
OVER 12,000 U.S. FARMS WENT OUT
OF BUSINESS IN 2017.
FARM INCOMES DROPPED 52% IN 5
YEARS.
BANKRUPTCIES ARE UP 33% IN THE
PAST 2 YEARS.
>> AND TWO KEY UNIVERSITIES
INFORMED US THAT THE FARMS THEY
USE TO MODEL ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
ARE IN POOR CONDITION.
>> AND THEY HAVE THE HIGHEST
SUICIDE RATE OF ANY U.S.
OCCUPATION.
>> EVEN IF THEY ARE PRODUCTIVE
THINGS ESCALATE TO ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION.
>> THE NEW FARM BILL ADDRESSES
THESE CONCERNS.
EXTENDING ACCESS TO LOANS.
ONE AMENDMENT THE STRESS ACT
WOULD PROVIDE COUNSELLING TO
DISTRAUGHT FARMERS.
JOHNSON IS WILLING TO ACCEPT ALL
OF THOSE FOR THE LIFE HE'S
CHOSEN.
>> AS MUCH BLOOD, SWEAT AND
TEARS I PUT ON THIS PLACE.
YOU WOULD HAVE A HARD TIME TO
GET ME AWAY FROM.
IT I ENJOY WHAT WE DO HERE.
I AM PROUD OF IT.
IT'S A TOUGH LIFE.
>> IT'S NOT ALL GLOOM AND DOOM.
FRUSTRATION WITH CITY LIFE AND
THE MOVEMENT TO ORGANIC AND
LOCALLY GROWN FOODS IS SPARKING
A RENAISSANCE OF YOUNG FARMERS